Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the Cup Castle War Challenge
We don't even know *shoots camera*
Ooh sh-
Matthias: Nice shot!
I didn't know it was loaded!
haahaaha
Uhe he
Matthias: You actually shot the camera!
Yeah!
So welcome to the Cup Castle War Challenge where we're gonna be shooting these guns
at that table, where the other team is gonna be trying to build a castle of cups
and we're trying to stop them with Nerf guns [shoots gun]
and then we're gonna shoot it over there,
trying to knock it down.
Now they-
J-Fred: STOP.
(Mark freezes)
Matthias: What?
Matthias: Um, water.
Matthias: ... Now we're good.
So yeah, so they have a few rules:
they can only knock it down with their hands by standing behind the masking tape, and-
Matthias: -block it. (Matthias lashes out right hand to demonstrate)
Yeah, block it with, block the Nerf bullets with their hand or whatever subterfuges that they have.
So, here we go!
*Intense BGM*
If a cup falls on the ground,
you can't put it back on the table. So, alright.
Ready?
Bryan: Alright, I'm gonna start it.
Okay, (3)
2, 1, GO!
*intense music starts*
Team Edge: I'm scared! (You better be!)
Team Edge: Guys, make sure you-
Well, they got one layer
Team Edge: We gotta take these same cups and put them in the front.
Team Edge: Wait, so how [shot] are we scoring this?
*Markimoo reloads gun* This is pretty weak
[Mark shoots]
Oh!
[Markimoo giggles]
Team Edge: No, no!
Matthias: oh
Matthias: Oh man, I'm worried about that one side- that side
Bryan: Good job, you block, alright, you block, I'll be the wall
J-Fred: These are going so fast!
J-Fred: No, they're- they're so fast!
Bryan: Block 'em, build a wall!
J-Fred: They're so fast!
Bryan: Block 'em, oh!
[Whirring noises]
Mark: I gotta reload!
Team Edge: Oh!
[laughter]
Bryan: Oh. what are you doing!? just block!
J-Fred: I can't block that!
J-Fred: They're so fast!
[Whirring noises of intimidation]
Matthias: Ah!
J-Fred: Those guns are loud!
[indistinguishable mutterings from Team Markimoo's side]
Mark: It's intimidation by noise.
Matthias: some guy hit me in the leg and it hurt. (Ow?)
Ryan: Already?
Mark: You're out of bullets, you're out of bullets.
Team Edge: Alright they're reloading, they're reloading.
Matt: I had like three bullets in here.
Team Kidsiplier: Reload! Reload!
[Cups clattering]
[Matthias' squeals with frustration]
Bryan: What happened there?
*Markiplier shoots*
Team Edge: OH!
Matthias: It's so loud and so crowded!
Bryan: You're not even close!
J-Fred: He's not even picking them up!
Matthias: I got to wear googles *ping*
Bryan: Put em back up! No!!
Matthias: Dude, this is a mess!
J-fred: How are we doing this?
Bryan: The highest. The highest level. The highest level...
Markiplier: *pleading tone* reloooad!!
Matt: I only had like 5 bullets..
Markiplier: Oooh yeah, we weren't fully loaded beforehand.
Matthias: Who are you Donald Trump? (BURN)
Markilplier: *Glorious laugh*
Matt: Oh I-I got a lot.
Matthias: I got this man!
Matthias: No - Joey stop it!
Bryan: Wait we can't build it we hafta- ....
J-Fred: No, stop. Stop.
Matthias: What are you doing !?
Bryan: It fell over! This is madness!
Bryan: BLOCK! Block! Block! Block! Block!
*Says a lot of something*
Matt: I-I gotta save it. I gotta save it for the right moment.
Team Edge: Oh, a different level
J-Fred: OH, WHY DID I GIVE IT BACK TO EM.
Matt: Wait, where is it?
Matthais: NO. NO.
Matthias: You gotta block dude!
J-Fred: I'm trying, it's impossible!!
J-Fred:It's so bad!
Matthias:You have to block!
Matt: This is rigged. They let the battery run out. (Sure Matt)
Markiplier: We'll sabotage. Throw the axe.
J-Fred: *nervous* what?
J-Fred: I pick em up- I keep trying to pick 'em up off the ground.
Matt: Don't do that!! Don't do that.
Bryan: Oh okay that was close, don't let that one get shot!
*unintelligible talking*  [Mark shoots the gun as though it was his job]
Markiplier: OOHH
[J-Fred flails arms in a fruitless attempt to stop the all-powerful Markimoo]
[Wipes brow in exhaustion]
J-Fred: Aw, I smell!
Matthias: mark  the timer!
Markimoo: Three minutes! We gotta go, We gotta go!
Mark:  Get it good, buddy, get it good!
[Yells of frustration as the clock ticks down...]
Mark:  I knew we should have...
[Clock beeps really quietly]
Team Edge:  Time, time, time, TIME, TIME!
TIME!
[Markimoo laughing]
Matt:  The battery died!
Matthias:  He got one, he got one, but it was time.
Matthias:  What happened?
Mark:  I think you had a third one up there that I knocked down after time.
Mark:  Pretty sure --
Matthias: It was like this, and then it was like "time," and then you were like:
Matthias:  PFFF!
[Marki Laughing]
Mark:  I got really good at reloading this bad boy.
POP, POP, POP
DING!
Ready!
Bryan:  3, 2, 1, GO!
Matthias:  Don't waste a shot
Matt:  I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Matthias:  This is great!
[J-Fred shoots]
Matthias:  Wait, why waste a shot?!
J-Fred:  I just wanted to.
[Guns whirring]
[BANG!]
Team Kidsiplier:  Ah!  Oh, oh, AH!
Mark:  [girly squeal] ah!
Ryan:  NO!
Ryan:  STOP!
Matthias:  Yes!
Ryan:  [girly scream]
Team Edge:  YES!
Matthias:  Yes!
J-Fred:  AH, you can't pick them up off the ground!
Matthias:  OHHH!
Ryan:  [Rage quit]
Matthias:  huh - HA!
[Guns whirring some more]
Matt:  Stop, STOP!
Matthias: This is THE GAME, Matt.
Mark: It's not okay!
Ryan: [hoarsely] This isn't a game!
Mark: Told ya, do it for real though, it's gonna get ya.
Ryan:*girly screams*
Team Edge: Two minutes, two minutes
Team Edge: Oh, there was a bullet in the way.
Matthias: What?
Bryan: You shoot all of yours first, then when you're out I start shooting.
Matthias: Okay, okay.
J-Fred: Crap, crap, this isn't going well. We don't have the-
Matthias: We got this, man. We got this.
Mark: I told you about the reload problem
Matthias: [Laughter] We should've listened to his tip!
J-Fred: [shooting] Oh, no!
Bryan: Alright, I'll shoot after you're out of your ammo
J-Fred: What the heck, that was low!
Bryan: Okay
Matt: No, NO, NO!
Team Edge: [silly noises]
Mark:Here it comes again
Ryan:NO!
[Everyone yelling in anger]
Matthias: What? You're wasting-
[More yelling on Mark's team]
Matthias: 1:30 left, 1:30 left!
Matthias: Who's next, who's next?
Bryan: I got a grenade I gotta wait till the end
Matthias: No no don't do the grenade wait till the end
Bryan: Here I go
Mark: [gets shot in the stomach] Ah!
Mark: Oooh, ahh.. oh shit.
Matt: Ryan, no!
Matthias: I got Ryan's terror right here.
Ryan:It's fine... (Mark: ow)...it's fine.
Mark's team: Noooooo!
Matthias: Yes! I made it fall! ...Oh I ran out too
Bryan: A minute left
Team Edge: [incoherent chatter]
Mark: Ow
Mark: Not me!
Matthias: Dude, look at Ryan get it!
Mark's team:NONNONONONONO
Matthias:  Get Ryan!
Mark's team: Stop it... [screaming]
Bryan: 35 seconds.
Ryan: 35 let's just protect these two, just protect these two with your life
Matt: Stop it!
[Tower falls] Matt: NO!
Team Edge: Cheers (while Mark's team proceeds with "nonononono")
Ryan: more girly screams of pressure
Mark: ow, ow, ow, ow, ow
Matthias: Yes!
[All yelling "time!"]
Mark: YeeEEEAAAAHHHH!
Mark's Team: [Lots of boasting]
Mark: Alright, so we absolutely crushed the opposition
morally, they are completely devastated they're, emotionally they're like, hurt to the core.
Mark: AAaah
Matt: Bryan has to go to therapy.
Mark: Yeah, they all have to to therapy it's really sad.
Mark: SO, um,
J-fred: I had to go to therapy before this
Mark: But once they're done with therapy, we're gonna have a rematch over on their channel.
Mark: So click the link down in the description below to go to Team Edge and find out who won the rematch
Mark: It's probably gonna be us because we are amazing at this.
J-Fred: Yeah, it's probably gonna be them.
Mark: Okay, we'll see ya there.
[Everyone saying bye]